tonight we continue our reports from
states in which Republicans are trying
to flip US Senate seats in the fall
midterms coming up this evening
correspondent Peter Doocy is in Ohio as
the GOP candidates try to align their
political careers with those of an
outsider president just a few blocks
away from the arena where a businessman
with no political experience officially
accepted the Republican nomination for
president two years ago a businessman
with no political experience is trying
to win a Republican nomination for
Senate he's kind of blazed the trail
he's been very effective and he's
accomplished an awful lot for the good
of America and I'd like to follow in
those footsteps
if investment banker Mike Gibbons is
going to unseat Democratic senator
sherrod Brown he's got to get his name
out there we put 65,000 miles on our car
the other Republican in the race
Congressman Jim Renee C says President
Trump is the reason he's running - I
really it was a call from the White
House
Renee C was initially running for
governor but when a high profile
Republican dropped out of the Senate
race for family reasons the president
nudged him towards this contest I've
said that all along poor kid from
western Pennsylvania gets asked by the
president and the White House to help
I'm gonna do it the president has been
supportive of Renee C an early endorser
will be back Jim get in there and fight
get in there and fight we need you Trump
beat Clinton by 8 points here now the
progressive Democratic senator Brown
says he agrees with the Republican
president on one major issue in the
state my support of the president's move
on steel tariffs I think it's time we
draw a line on on Chinese misbehavior in
Chinese game in the system Renee see
doubts the Democratic senator is sincere
the one thing about senator Brown is
just a political year so he's going to
hug the president as much as you can the
sad thing is it can only hug him on one
issue and that's tariffs but Brown
insists not everything has to be
partisan voters don't look at liberals
conservatives in any kind of spectrum
they they look at each of us do you
fight for our pensions you fight for
higher wages do you fight for trade
agreements that mean
in the United States and then there are
the voters like Mike Gibbons who looked
at those choices and decided a name was
missing I decided to do something about
the fact that I've been throwing things
at my television set for the last 25
years one name you didn't hear just now
that of the Republican who won the last
big statewide primary in Ohio John
Kasich he's still the governor but is
making moves towards a 2020 presidential
run and is not someone these candidates
are clamoring to have joined them on the
campaign trail Bret Peter Doocy live in
Cleveland Peter thank you